اول ما صار الزلزال يعني بس انا اهم
الاولاد يعني بس انا احمله اولاد
[موسيقى]
بس
يعني ما بعرف انه احفر وين بدي اطلع اطلع
فوق ولا أدي كنت انزل تحت الارض ما بعرف
[موسيقى]
صرت احفر صيح انا اصيح صيح ما حدا يسمعني
صح بالتركي
[موسيقى]
طيب انت كيف انقذت نفسك بالاول خرجت بعدين
انقذت اسرتك ولا نفس المكان لا انا اول
شيء طلعت حالي يعني انا
صاير المحل اللي قاعد فيه قريب كتير على
البرنده
وصرت تشيل يعني احفر وشيل البلاط اللي
موجود بالارض لحتى طلعت يعني انا مو انه
شي وقت طلعت يعني طلعت من هون وبنحل كتير
كتير ضيق يعني بشكل مو طبيعي ضيق والاطفال
بعدين صرت احفروا يعني احفروا شي الحجار
[موسيقى]
شو شعورك كان وانت بتصرخ وبتنادي وما حدا
سامعك كل شيء يعني الرعب لحاله بيكفي
الخوف يعني اقل شيء يطلب مساعده ما حدا
يلبيه لحد الان صوتها بيبالنا
سويت هيك وصار الي صار يعني
[موسيقى]